you know who I've I've been chatting
with my Sweetwater
rep well yeah dude uhhuh I put in a huge
order on Sweet Water yeah and I knew it
I knew that I knew that call was coming
did he send a pick of his underwear did
he send an upskirt while it's the Sweet
Water hey Cody just put your order
together you're like hey
Phil good to see you man thought you
forgot about me yeah oh I'm sorry I
would never that's the next step for
Sweet Water honestly yeah yeah oh yeah
just nudes just unsolicited
nudes yo what's up Steve your your
Sweetwater rep how do you like these
Sweet
Waters oh
dude no dud it's Sweet Water this is so
stupid it's like oh did you just send me
a
tribute it's a picture in my order it's
a picture of My Sweet Water order with
[__] all over it how you like this Sweet
Water oh that's that's that's good
that's
dude we love your order here we are
loving your order just a picture of him
on his knees on his knees with saail on
his
face just got your sweet water order so
excited so I bought this [__] and then
I'm sitting there with my phone on my
desk I'm like I know it's coming I know
it's coming literally in like 2 minutes
flat I get the call Sweetwater sound
it's like Cody long time no sock or
something like
that saw you saw your order yeah saw
your
order like what are you are you going
for a run or something dude
nope oh
[__] transported me there man but he he
was like uh he's like yeah man I still
you know I still work with uh Noel still
work with um oh so we got the same guy I
think
so let me see yeah that's our TMG rap
yeah yeah so he mentioned everyone I was
like God damn dude yeah and he's like
cuz I know you've been uh you know doing
the dance music stuff and he knew
everything he's like I know you just
came out with a new or you got a new
song coming out or something like that
and I was like I was like d so I'm sorry
man how do you know
that and he was like I been working with
you guys for a long time and I was like
so you're the same [__] guy it's been
years now I'm texting him right now
hey dude he text me in August by my
order I said hey hey dude it just just
say what are you
wearing swe Walker is actually
headquartered in my hometown he's
probably in Indiana no oh damn oh this
is [__] Zach's high school bully
yeah he sent me a photo wearing a TMG
hat one day no way was he naked no he
had all his clothes on okay good yeah
[__] can I read you this yeah yeah yeah
read me this hamster post yeah I read
the top line I'm like I'm leaving this
for the
day okay my hamster
exploded I've been crying in my room for
2 hours now I was making some salad
dressing in the kitchen with my pet
hamster Manny I let him Ro around my
sister and her friends were also in
there doing something pause pause pause
why would you let it roam around it's
like that big no that's what Brooke does
she's like a rabbit doesn't she like a
guinea pig or something a guinea pig she
like lets it yeah but still guinea pig
is like you like a hamster is yeah
they're pretty small they're like this
big they're tiny they're not that tiny
yeah they're pretty small you have to
two-hand them yeah and they're fragile
yeah if if you pick it up like this
you'll kill it I don't think so really
yeah my sister had one it's not that
fragile it was pretty I held one
in it was like maybe it was a baby yeah
yeah okay why did you hold a hamster
man we went to one of those like we went
to one of those Hedgehog cafes hamster
squashing places yeah we went to those
yeah it's really weird it's an allh room
they just put in your hand are stomping
yeah well and you just see on a board it
just says 321
clap you have to clap as hard as you can
yeah they have graphite on both of the
gloves yeah see that's a baby isn't it
that thing's cute as hell that's what we
had was like a tiny all right now squash
it
yeah yeah that's what I felt like I
could do yeah anyway I let it roam
around bold moves my sister and her
friends were also in there doing
something I spilled a bottle of vinegar
so I left to get a towel and when I came
back Manny was drinking it I didn't
think anything of it so I let him help
me clean it up all of a
sudden all of a sudden Manny starts
acting really weird he's normally very
full of energy but he was just sitting
still everyone gathered around him to
try to figure out what was wrong
suddenly we hear a fizzling noise coming
from inside Manny and he started
expanding he let out a final squeak and
bursted Bubbles and blood went
everywhere my sister and her friends
started screaming and crying I ran and
got my dad and he cleaned it up we
looked in the pantry and apparently
Manny got into the baking soda and ate a
bunch of it I think I'm traumatized
now oh my
god oh no man he got
JFK oh no I don't think I've ever heard
of a hamster who died normally of old
AG I
think I think more hamsters have died in
people's asses than yeah of old age yeah
you know yeah that's a good point I
didn't even process how easy it is to
get a hamster in your ass until right
now yeah we've talked about that before
no but I didn't have the scale I didn't
have a point of reference yeah yeah so
they must be pretty small very yeah yeah
damn I wonder how much it expand see
that's a hamster to me that's the size
yeah no no no the top left one oh yeah
thicker yeah that was my sister's
hamster bit of
a and it was it was it was yeah it was
it was a little tough tough getting him
up up my
ass well you guys didn't take
turns no my no my sister didn't know
that I was doing that okay got it got it
it just the tone you Ed you said up my
ass yeah yeah I think it's cuz I
stuttered five times when I said that so
that's why probably it was a confession
man I'm proud of you yeah
yeah it's my
truth yeah I don't know why you let it
roam
around yeah I don't know you're kind of
asking for that to happen yeah with how
fragile they are poor hamsters man I
didn't know hamster deaths you're just
doomed immediately from the beginning
yeah yeah some shit's going to happen to
you if you're a hamster well you know
the whole thing about the moms eat their
uh kids hamster moms eat the no oh yeah
they'll devour those [__] like
parrots yeah why I think it's a it's two
things hamsters eat all the time don't
they uh I don't know yeah I thought they
just always are kind of perpetually so
my understanding is they eat the kids
cuz they taste good m no no it's cuz uh
you know they The Forbidden meat The
Forbidden meat
yeah you see that picture that Army
Hammer oh feeling stressed anxiety oh my
God they're stress eating I thought it
was cuz they thought it was there's
potentially something wrong with the kid
damn so they're stress eating but
instead of just like ice cream and
cookies it's their own children
yeah you see the picture that Army
Hammer posted on Thanksgiving was it a
plate full of [__] ham babies no it
just said it said gobble gobble # gooble
gobble or something like that and
everyone was like this is kind of a
weird post when you're accused of
cannibalism a person tied up on his
table Yeah gobble
gobble